FOR US.
GREAT WORK AS ALWAYS, PETER
DOOCY.
>> LET'S GET REACTION FROM
CAPITOL HILL.
REPUBLICAN SENATOR FROM
TENNESSEE AND MEMBER OF THE
SENATE HOUSING AND URBAN
AFFAIRS, FOREIGN RELATIONS AND
SENATE COMMITTEES.
THANK YOU FOR SPENDING YOUR
SATURDAY WITH US FOR A LITTLE
WHILE.
>> CERTAINLY.
>> I WANT TO START WITH TITLE
42 AND THIS RULING.
IT'S GOING TO STAY FOR NOW.
AT SOME POINT REALISTICALLY,
TITLE 42 IS GOING AWAY.
I KNOW THAT YOU AND OTHER
PARTIES WANT A VOTE ON TITLE 42
TO KEEP IT IN PLACE.
DO YOU THINK YOU CAN GET THAT
SUPPORT NOW FROM THE OTHER SIDE
OF THE AISLE NOW THAT WE'VE
SEEN THIS RULING COME DOWN.
GRIFF: DO YOU THINK YOU CAN GET
THAT SUPPORT?
>> WELL, ALL THIS RULING IS IS
A STAY OF EXECUTION, WE HAVE A
MASSIVE CRISIS AT THE SOUTHERN
BORDER THIS PAST MONTH SAW THE
GREATEST NUMBER OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS COME INTO THE
COUNTRY THAN WE'VE SEEN.
IN MY HOME STATE OF TENNESSEE
WE HAVE EACH MONTH MORE
OVERDOSES AND DEATHS FROM
FENTANYL COMING ACROSS THAT
BORDER THAN WE'VE HAD BEFORE.
IT GETS WORSE BY THE MONTH.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
DOING EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO
TRANSFORM AMERICA AND TITLE 42
IS THE LAST TOOL LEFT FOR OUR
BORDER PATROL AGENTS TO PUSH
BACK.
I THINK IT'S BIGGEST PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS IS THE DEATHS
FROM OVERDOSES, THE BIGGEST
KILLER OF YOUNG AMERICANS
BETWEEN AGES 18 AND 45 IN
AMERICA IS OVERDOSE DEATHS.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WILL
NOT ACKNOWLEDGE IT.
>> SENATOR, DHS SENATOR
MAYORKAS HAS BEEN ON THE HILL
QUITE A FEW TIMES AND I KNOW
THAT SEVERAL MEMBERS OF YOUR
PARTY BELIEVE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS FAILING IN
ITS IMMIGRATION POLICIES, BUT
MAYORKAS AND OTHERS WOULD SAY
THAT CONGRESS ISN'T DOING
ENOUGH FOR IMMIGRATION REFORM.
ARE YOU WILLING TO WORK WITH
YOUR DEMOCRATIC COLLEAGUES ON
THE HILL TO COME TOGETHER AND
PUT TOGETHER SOME KIND OF
IMMIGRATION PACKAGE TO DEAL
WITH THIS IN THE LONG-TERM?
>> I'M WILLING TO WORK WITH THE
DEMOCRATS AND ANYBODY TO GET
THIS FIXED.
NO ONE ON THE DEMOCRATIC SIDE
WILL STEP UP.
AND I PUT LEGISLATION TO EXPAND
TITLE 42 AMONG THE PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS, DRUG OVERDOSE
DEATHS AND I COULDN'T GET A
SINGLE DEMOCRAT TO JOIN ME IN
THE CONVERSATION.
CONGRESS IS READY TO ACT ON OUR
SIDE OF THE AISLE TO MAKE TITLE
42 PERMANENT AND WE NEED THE
MIGRANT PROTECTIONS IN PLACE
AND THAT WAS WORKING.
BIDEN WON'T GO TO THE BORDER TO
ADDRESS THE CRISIS AND IT'S
CRUSHING AMERICA.
>> AND ONE MORE ON TITLE 42,
AND INFLATION AS WELL.
I WENT TO THE TIJUANA BORDER
SAW THINGS ON THE GROUND
FIRSTHAND AND THERE ARE PLACES
IN MEXICO THAT OFFER STABILITY
AND SAFETY FOR SOME OF THESE
MIGRANTS.
SHOULD MEXICO BE DOING MORE TO
INCENTIVIZE SOME OF THESE
PEOPLE COMING FROM THIS TRY
TRIANGLE COUNTRIES TO DO MORE?
>> AND THAT'S WHAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP DID, HE PUT A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF PRESSURE ON THE
MEXICAN GOVERNOR AND THEY WERE
PATROLLING THE BORDERS.
NOW IT'S CREEDED CEDED TO THE
CARTELS.
IF WE WOULD GO BACK TO THE
POLICIES THAT WERE WORKING WE
WOULD HAVE A TREMENDOUS IMPACT
ON REDUCING THIS CRISIS.
INSTEAD.
PEOPLE ARE PILING UP ON THE
BORDER, AND THEY'RE TURNED AWAY
WITH TITLE 42, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS SENDING
SIGNALS THEY'LL DO AWAY WITH
IT.
IF THEY DO DO AWAY WITH IT
WE'LL HAVE A TSUNAMI.
>> AND OTHER THINGS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT ARE GAS PRICES.
YOU CAN'T GO ANYWHERE AND NOT
SEE LESS THAN $4 A GALLON.
AND YET, THE SENATE APPROVED
$40 BILLION AID TO UKRAINE.
THE NEW YORK TIMES EDITORIAL
BOARD WROTE A PIECE URGING THE
PRESIDENT TO RECONSIDER OUR
INVESTMENT IN UKRAINE, OR AT
LEAST COME UP WITH A MORE
DETAILED PLAN, AN END-GAME.
AND THEY WRITE THIS, AS THE WAR
CONTINUES, MR. BIDEN SHOULD
ALSO MAKE CLEAR TO PRESIDENT
VOLODYMYR ZELENSKYY AND HIS
PEOPLE THAT THERE IS A LIMIT TO
HOW FAR THE UNITED STATES AND
N.A.T.O. ARE WILLING TO GO.
WILL GO TO CON FRONT RUSSIA AND
LIMITS TO THE ARMS MONEY AND
POLITICAL SUPPORT THEY CAN
MUSTER.
SENATOR, DO YOU BELIEVE THAT
UKRAINE CAN WIN THIS WAR OR DO
WE NEED TO START COMING UP WITH
SOME KIND OF END-GAME, A
COMPROMISE, PERHAPS?
>> WELL, UKRAINE CAN WIN THE
WAR AND WE NEED TO COME UP WITH
A FULLY STRATEGIC APPROACH TO
THIS.
THE BEST THING WE COULD DO IS
ACTUALLY END THE WAR ON
AMERICAN ENERGY HERE, THAT
WOULD DEFUND VLADIMIR PUTIN'S
WAR MACHINE.
THAT'S WHAT WE NEED TO DO FIRST
AND FOREMOST.
THE $40 BILLION WE'RE SENDING
THERE NOW IS THE SIZE OF MY
STATE OF TENNESSEE'S ANNUAL
BUDGET.
AND WHEN BIDEN SPENDING LIKE
THIS LITTLE OVERSIGHT AND
DETAILS INVOLVED IN THIS.
THERE ISN'T AN END GAME.
WE SHOULD BE WALKING SIDE BY
SIDE, WITH OUR COLLEAGUES IN
EUROPE.
WE'RE AT PARITY, BUT WITH THIS
$40 BILLION FOR WHAT THEY'RE
SPENDING.
WE NEED TO BRING THEM ALONG AND
LOOK AT THIS HOLISTICALLY AND
SOLVING THE ENERGY CRISIS AT
THE SAME TIME AND ADDRESS
INFLATION AT HOME.
>> I IMAGINE AS GAS PRICES
CONTINUE TO RISE AND SEE THINGS
LIKE THE BABY FORMULA SHORTAGE
HAPPEN, AMERICANS WILL CONTINUE
TO ASK THIS QUESTION.
SENATOR, THANK YOU